[Música]
mais um livro para a minha caixa do
conhecimento
mas espera aí caixa do conhecimento
caixa conhecimento
vocês têm alguma idéia do que é vamos
ver
uma dica ela abre portas para a
criatividade a literatura eo
conhecimento à literatura os livros
trazem muito conhecimento me aumenta a
nossa criatividade melhor na escrita
desenvolve um pensamento crítico e
intelectual e nos trazem emoções se
estamos lendo um livro de terror
temos vontade de olhar uma debaixo da
cama para ver se não tem nenhum monstro
mesmo mas estamos lendo um livro de ação
e nosso herói ganha temos vontade de
comemorar mas faltou nós uma assunto
principal o que a caixa do conhecimento
a caixa do conhecimento é simplesmente
uma caixa cheia de livros que podem ser
de crianças adultos de todos os tipos
ela deve ser levada em um local onde as
pessoas não têm o hábito da leitura por
sua qualidade de vida por isso que eu
criei meu projeto pois não o hábito de
leitura para mim é muito importante e
sempre ajuda das minhas produções de
texto e na língua portuguesa
o legal seria você isso trocar os seus
amigos vizinhos parentes para você ter
livros novos toda hora mas você acha que
é difícil montar uma caixa do
conhecimento
se você está pensando que é você está
pensando completamente errado é muito
rápido muito fácil rápido e divertido
com certeza você deve ter livros em sua
casa estão em suas prateleiras gavetas
armários que você não está usando
vamos por ele para rodar o mundo pega
uma caixa que o governo ter no meu caso
que você tem em sua casa e coloque dos
seus livros dentro dele e leve para um
local onde você acha que as pessoas
nesse necessitam
vocês gostaram está apta a caixa feita
por mim
vocês podem observar que têm dívidas de
todos os tipos no meu objetivo foi para
as crianças
a minha primeira experiência foi na
oratória são bento que fica dentro do
mosteiro são bento no local e minha mãe
meu pai de um catequese e eu fiz a minha
catequese lá durante a catequese eu
conheci esse local onde crianças
carentes são ajudados por dentistas
médicos psicólogos voluntários e eu
também que ser voluntário
fui lá levei minha caixa expliquei meu
projeto e minha experiência com os
livros que animou muito eles na hora que
eu deixei eles pegarem os livros eles
fizeram uma fila e pegavam até dois
livros
foi muito legal e o que mais emocionou
foi a alegria das crianças elas sentavam
juntos conversavam sobre os livros se
interagiam foi muito divertido e com
todo esse divertimento alegria trouxe um
resultado excelente as crianças ficaram
contentes com o meu projeto e df pediram
para ficar mais um tempo com a caixa do
conhecimento só ajudando esses falaram
que elas pegavam 23 livros e ainda
queriam mais
obrigado pela sua atenção e espero que
tenham gostado do meu projeto agora tem
um desafio para todos vocês não só a
taxa do conhecimento também
[Aplausos]
[Música]